Ngày một bệnh thần một, đây vừa tên giản thân thông tin từ ABC News cho biết chính quyền Mỹ đã yêu cầu
về nươi là cân đất quan hệ kinh tế với li bằng ngà Trung Quốc, Ivan và Kuba.
Ngươi muốn tăng sản lượng khai tháng và xuất khẩu giống mỏ.
Thông tin này dự chín tất lộ của băng nguồn thảo tin về kế hoạch của nhà trắng.
Theo ABC News, Washington đến nghĩ Karitas chỉ hợp tác độc quyền với Mỹ trong lĩnh vực giấu khi
và ưu tiên bản dầu thong cho các cộng tin Mỹ.
Thông thông đôi nân trong cho rằng, Nành dầu mỏ với Nươi là bị quốc hữu hóa không công bằng và cân được mở cửa trở lại cho xuân nghiệp Mỹ.
Đồng tháng này, giễn ra sâu kì Mỹ đến hành chiếc quân sự tại Karitas, bắt sửa tổng thống Nikolas Maduro.
Vìa với Nươi là thẳng định Mỹ muốn chiếm đoạn muôn tăng quyền dầu mỏ của nước này.
Cung ngày Mỹ, tin bố số dòng, dầu về Nươi là bản dầu sẽ được bản theo sả tìm trường.
Chúc hi đó các hẳn tin của tính nhận định.
Biał Washington Kim Sun Môn Giò về Nươi là có thể làm thấy đổi cán tin công ứng nâng lợng đặc biệt là đôi.